i mean like for the longest time we were
like literally trapped in this country
because we couldn't fly out for the
longest time
and it's just been it was only recently
that the rules got changed that people
who are already residents can fly out
and then fly back in
and i mean now we're just waiting for
the actual you know people who are
waiting on visas because i you know i
can only imagine that that that does
suck you know because like like we were
really lucky to be able to get our visas
before all this happened otherwise we
would have literally trash taste would
have never happened yeah right if we
would had applied for our visas
literally a few months after we got our
visas yeah so we uh we would still be
waiting now to like even get our visas
to move to japan you know it's actually
crazy to think about and japan faced a
lot of criticism when the
when the chronovirus started because
they they banned um only japanese
nationals were allowed back in yeah
right which is like okay i guess that
makes sense but then they also didn't
allow uh green card holders permanent
residents um really yeah so if you're
married if you
uh if you're like me you're british and
you're married to a japanese woman and
then you went and then you came back in
though the my like if i was married to
japanese person they'd be allowed in but
i wouldn't be allowed in yeah
if someone's a permanent resident of
your country that's literally like where
their whole life is you can't just say
like no but they did and they faced a
lot of criticism which they did
eventually change but they've still been
banning visas and like i feel really
[ __ ] sorry for these these students
we've had their life on pause who wanted
who had their whole like basically two
years lined up in japan yeah they've
just been banned from entering japan
like they've been just been waiting yeah
and they haven't
it doesn't make sense to me that they
wouldn't allow some system even if it's
complicated and even if it's [ __ ]
stupid and tedious to get in if you're a
student yeah like i don't understand why
that why they haven't changed the rule
on that it's just japan being japan you
know yeah it's because japan thinks that
like oh the foreigners you're more
likely to get it if you're a foreigner
which is just not true yeah you know
it's just one of those things where you
know you can go through
enough precautions and you can do enough
tests to make sure that like 99 of the
time you'll get it so that it's good and
it works but i don't know to me it just
i just i can't fathom it while they're
bend
issuing any visas at all it really
doesn't make sense to me yeah i don't
know it's dumb as [ __ ] yeah and like
after going through that quarantine
experience like i i don't believe any
anyone who's flying in is like spreading
co-fit there's two people my god they
have this [ __ ] on lockdown man yeah
honestly um i mean yeah you need there's
like two tests when you get here in your
test before
obviously somehow someone did get
covered on my flight but they were that
was cool and then if you test positive
in the three days you you know you have
to yeah i i understand it can still slip
through yeah but also it feels like such
diminishing returns at this point
to keep this rule in place you know i
mean it's whatever i'm sure everyone
will have a personal opinion about it
and that stuff i i understand allowing
tourists in obviously i get that this is
like whatever i mean i feel like it's
different levels right there's tourists
uh which is which is opening the
floodgates but then there's people who
are like literally waiting on a working
order but it breaks my heart man i
really feel sorry for these people who
had their life lined up to come here and
they've just been just hanging around
waiting really i do feel so sorry for
them yeah it's so [ __ ] it's really
[ __ ] well hopefully soon i mean the
the cases are going down a lot nowadays
yeah yeah i saw an article today that
was like japan's uh drop in covert cases
baffles experts
but also i heard that japan isn't
testing as much so i mean yeah yeah
that's enough but i mean it's also
because like most young people now are
finally [ __ ] back yeah
have we missed anything since we've been
gone um um i mean the country's opened
back up again i mean in terms of like
the the lock down quite unquote i mean
i've
yeah so like
beginning of uh october they were like
oh yeah so uh everything's just good now
yeah oh everything's open you can drink
alcohol if you want everyone's like we
can drink are you are you sure
because you said that last time
yeah we did that last time we could only
do it for a week before you shut that
[ __ ] down again
it was just like the floodgates were
open everyone went out drinking and then
a week later everyone's just like well
that was
that was a good time yeah experts are
like yeah that's a bad idea let's not do
that the japanese government managed to
do something that i think they've never
done before
test the patience of their population
and piss them off yeah i've never seen
people get so actually angry about [ __ ]
yeah it just doesn't happen yeah but
people actually got so angry about them
keep extending the lockdown yeah because
they're so [ __ ] wishy-washy as well
they're like they're like oh yeah so uh
the cases are going down it's not zero
but it's going down so maybe we can open
it up again
and then the and then it goes back up
and they're like
well surprised that's a baffle surprise
pikachu
how did this happen it was going down
and the olympics just like blew it over
oh oh god yeah
oh my god just like i watched a video
about all the fuck-ups of the olympics
and it was insane yeah having it all in
one video yeah the sheer amount of
people that got fired off the olympic
committee is insane it was like half of
them yeah and then the amount of
controversy the olympic it was insane i
was like this is [ __ ] so [ __ ]
weird oh my god i mean so far it seems
to be going all right um i mean the
other day i was at a at a park
and with some of my friends and someone
was like
we should do a bold game of move we
should drink a beer in this park and i
was like it felt like if it felt like
someone just offered me cocaine i was
like no no
that's a good idea i think someone's
watching this this doesn't feel right
i did it was very liberating but
he [ __ ] the police yeah i was like
[ __ ] the police they can't stop us now
but um yeah i mean i don't know it's i'm
just waiting again for like next week
for the government to be late change
their minds yeah psych it's locked out
again well the real question is is
karaoke open because that's that's
that's everything that's how you know
lockdown's actually ended once the
karaoke opens that's like the equivalent
of like when the british pubs are open
so the karaokes are open uh restaurants
now go past eight o'clock you can order
alcohol basically everything's back to
normal well some of the restaurants are
still clothed
some restaurants yeah it's kind of
confusing now which is basically it's
basically most restaurants actually like
phil the day filming this this is
literally my first day of quarantine so
i i've i've not been out to explore the
town i've uh i've just been stuck in my
you're stuck in my house oh i sound like
andy dufresne
honestly i prefer like the three days of
my life in hotel i [ __ ] love my home
i was like oh my god i can work i have a
space i can walk i can walk around i can
i can [ __ ] in a bathroom that has a
bidet that's usable
your hotel you had a bidet but it was
like so weak okay i was like it was like
a duck like tickling my butthole i
wanted something to power wash my cheeks